سلام الله عليكم واسعد الله جميع اوقاتكم
معكم عبود وخبركم في اخر التطورات وما جرى
في 12 ديسمبر وهذا تاريخ النكبه بالنسبه
لي لقيت الساعه 12 في الليل 12 ديسمبر انا
مش عارف ديسمبر اول مره ص احكي انجليزي
انجليزي انا عارف يا راجل بكرون
برطاني الناس طقم طقيه على بلوزه من جوز
اختي عصر ايش فقمت من كل الدنيا تمام
ماحدش يحكيلي ليش الدوشه طل
اول مره
ظل المهم كنا في المستشفى المشته تمام
فجاه شفنا سمعين صوت دبابات شرفات بخيل
حوالينا المهم نمت
صحيت دبابه على باب المستشفى جرفه بتخيل
على باب دارنا بتج وبصر شوف مين هدول
المهم وقفلك الضابط جنب
الحيط مستشفى كامل عدو هيك بحكي مستشفى
كامل عدوان عليكم اخلاقها فوغا الله يحم
بالك ما تحكي عربي وتريحنا بتحكي لي نص
فصحى على نص بصار مين احكي ميداني المهم
قاعد يتهبل هيك 10 دقائق طلع انا طبعا انا
اول مره بدي اشوف جندي قال طالع اول واحد
م خباني المهم طلعنا ارفع ايديك ارفع
ايديك حاضر ابشر رحنا اخدونا على مستودع
دبابات
m